guys real quick you're not doing the
protest you can't just skip out chuckle
lotta you gonna let him talk to you like
that what are you doing there you're not
at the protest you just show you guys
walk out
yeah the officers like oh that's awful
you don't want to be there for the
protests are a link for the Pope over
there for like four minutes no last year
I went to the prelate last year yeah we
have a protest you lying to me chuckle
out there all right so moving on here is
um this was this was going on during the
weekend and if you bought into this will
Friday really but if you bought into
this idea that it was hashtag national
walk out huge the national school walk
out day that was a number one trend
everywhere we went to six different
schools to get to the body I hate to use
the term hoax because it's thrown around
so frequently and I think in this case
it is a hoax perpetrated on the American
public if you believed that this was a
massive movement certainly on a massive
scale and this is a grassroots movement
with with students you you were tricked
so uh well here you go we are the
experts this will be a generation long
thing and this is just getting started
there are people who stand against you
because you're too young we say no I
think this is a potentially a formidable
new group of political activists kids
need to organize because this is the
moment because this is exactly what
happened and the civil rights movement
it seems to me that expert David hog so
question of the day is did you think
that this was really a national movement
the national school walkout day hashtag
National Don Lemon today wall-to-wall
media coverage did you think this
majority or certainly a plurality the
student body were participating I mean
I'd like to see what you guys thought of
course freshmen you'd think to be riding
a tailwind after the first walk out with
the parklands to momentum boarded by
their black lives matter a lot of Soros
organizations Planned Parenthood the
women's martyr know what they have to do
with guns but it's this unholy alliance
that was created so there'd be able to
get enough students you would think for
the second rally but we attended them a
little bigger high schools in the area
not seeing anything in that point a
school of 18-under kid that doesn't it's
a movement like it's all teachers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow that was fast the event was canceled
[Music]
this what actually like it's pretty well
attended here at Woodrow Wilson High
School maybe 300 people until you
realize that a lot of them aren't aren't
students that's because you have
congressional candidate Colin Allred
speaking along with City Councilman
Philip clingstone and various community
leaders and members of the
administration according to the website
information so really it's it's more of
a political rally held on a campus track
as a matter of fact it was hard to tell
the students from the people who were
there to register them to vote excuse me
hey can I ask what what grades are you
guys in at that school look you don't go
here oh I'm sorry we're getting people
to sign up right what do they read
register to vote but they're not 18
though you're not then you're not in any
great here are you a student here we're
trying to get an accurate head count hey
guys
guys real quick you're not doing the
protest you can't just skip out chuckle
Otto you're gonna let him talk to you
like that what are you doing there
you're not at the protest you just show
you guys walk out
yeah the officers was like gum that's
awful you don't want to be there for the
protest are a link for the folktale you
were there for like four minutes no last
year I went to the approach last year
yeah we have a protest action you lying
to me chuckle out there and the protest
is that way yeah but it's last period
you got to get back to class if you're
not in the protest it's not us it's skip
class home yeah I bet you do
there's still one more period going on
in school they just started the last
period so these are all students that
are walking out for a last period okay
do they get attention or suspension for
walking out oh they get more captain
that's it now the teacher just informed
us that if you leave this is before last
period you're just marked as absent yes
you're Pouncy
by the way the numbers that we're giving
you that includes all of the faculty
security protesters protesting the from
the counter protesters and by the way
people who are just leaving class
because they have a free pass I am
amazed the numbers not a hundred percent
there were more people who walked out of
class at my high school
protesting better quality toilet paper
Centennial Regional High School you can
look that up I walked out and I loved
their toilet paper okay change look what
kind of change you talking about you
think need violence in that school
yeah I'm not only anyone wants violence
in the school there's your movie
David hog should have passed out candy
so given the numbers at what point does
this become a hoax perpetrated on the
American public as far as the idea of it
being a grassroots movement in which a
plurality of the student body
participated now that being said I can't
blame the people who gained the system
and gained the system many of them did
dude come on man hey check a lot a check
a lot eh
I'm filming make good decisions promise
promise channel update come here come
here tell me tell me tell me just come
here and promise me on camera okay Chuck
a latte you're gonna make better
decisions hey did you enjoy this video
here's the thing your role you're here
this is the end of it so we don't care
cuz you already watched it but if you
really didn't like it and you want to
justify it leave a comment below telling
us why you didn't like the video and if
you liked us let us know and subscribe
to the channel because that lets the
overlords at YouTube know that you know
what you're alright